Okay. Meanwhile,
back here on Earth,
the New York presidential
primary is next week,
renewing the debate
over some harsh criticism
of New York
coming from the right.
You suggested Mr. Trump
"embodies New York values."
Could you explain
what you mean by that?
You know, I think
most people know
exactly what
New York values are.
(fake chuckle)
I think most people know exactly
how slimy and creepy you are.
(cheering and applause)
(whimpering)
You know what?
I'll tell you what. I'll tell
you about New York values.
No, wait, guys, it's not fair.
I've only lived here,
like, a year and a half.
You know what,
here's a native New Yorker
to talk
about real New York values.
♪ Welcome to my c-city... ♪
(cheering and applause)
Thank you!
(crowd chanting "Bernie!")
And thank you, Larry.
That's right.
It's me,
Bernie Brooklyn-born Sanders.
And guess what, Ted Cruz,
I have New York values.
(cheering and applause)
I value a living wage
for all Americans.
I value a justice system
that treats everyone fairly.
I value a government
which works for all of us,
not just Wall Street
and powerful special interests.
Those are New York values.
(cheering and applause)
Right?
And you know what New York is?
It's a place built
by the backbreaking work
of immigrants.
Immigrants like your family,
Ted Cruz.
And when you say having
New York values is a bad thing,
you insult my city, my state,
my culture, and my heritage.
I am the son of an immigrant,
and I am proud of it.
(cheering and applause)
You started... you started
this New York values nonsense
as an attack on Trump,
and I've got some New York
values for him, too.
(laughter)
Mr. Trump, you wouldn't know
New York values
if they were written
in 50-foot gold letters
on the side
of the Empire State Building.
(cheering and applause)
New York values are
the Statue of Liberty,
not a wall between us
and Mexico.
In New York, we pride ourselves
on our diversity.
We don't divide people up
based on where they were born.
I was born and raised
in Brooklyn.
BK, stand up! Fight back!
Don't let anyone tear us down!
(cheering and applause)
I will never lose the values
that New York and my family
have given me.
As New Yorkers, we understand
what New York values
really mean.
We believe in the value
of hard work.
of equality.
We believe in the value
of a society
where the American dream
works for all,
not just the one percent.
Those are New York values.
And the truth is New York values
are American values.
There is no difference.
(cheering and applause)
Oh! Oh!
Oh, man! Oh!
Bernie Sanders, everybody!
We'll be right back
with more Bernie!
Oh, Bernie, you dropped the mic!
Oh, my God!